Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie. This is going
to be my Agents of SHIELD Episode 6 WTF video.
We finally found out who Lash is, it's a big
WTF even though it was somewhat predicted.
They did a pretty good job of seeding clues.
And it's a big change from the comics. Just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen the
episode yet most of the crazier stuff first
and then work our way down so starting with
number five Andrew is Lash so the in the middle
of making my flash video to Tuesday night
when agent to shield with Barry and people
started tweeting at me about Andrew being
Lash, I was actually really surprised sometimes
even if the story is telling you one thing
the writers will take it in a different direction
so love or hate the change from the comics
like in the comics Andrew is not Lash
Lash is a completely different character on a completely
different type of mission what they're doing
seems very similar like Lash in the comics
goes around killing a bunch of new in humans
TV show Lash doing the exact same thing but
their motivation is completely different so
I will give the writers a hat tip for staying
true to their own story I know that there
was like to do comic book stuff whenever they
can but the big twists always need to be in
service of the story not not so much paying
off comic books so they been teasing Roslyn
as a frenemy that Sky hates when she's
really trusting of Andrew so now she's gonna
have to learn to trust Roslyn is probably
an end up helping them deal with their Lash
problem conflict inside the group is the name
of the game is just like the Ward twist during
season one wolf in the henhouse they actually
twisted that phrase in a funny way for season
two episode where mockingbird was secretly
inside Hydra I think it was like hen in the
Wolf house or something like that one of the
other big reason that I thought that Andrew
might be Lash which is lack of evidence for
other characters being Lash like it was too
obvious like they were trying to make Roslyn
seem like too much of an antagonist when really
she has so much chemistry with Coulson that
of course are going to be working together
Andrew has zero chemistry with may even though
they were supposed to have been married so
maybe they play those scenes like that on
purpose they want you to feel uneasy about
him even though he's the psychiatrist he supposed
to make everybody feel better about themselves
and like that Ward twist like you learn to
anticipate things like that, so you guys can let me
know, i mean do you like Andrew
as Lash I feel like it's a really interesting
twist first character now he is interesting
he was really that interesting before speaking of which
on the number four Andrew is trying to
go after Lincon and not just lincon specifically
just to be clear he's trying to get rid of
all those new in humans my thought is is that
he feels like he is helping like all these
in humans are causing all this trouble Rosalind's
group has their way of dealing with it Lash
has his way of dealing with it or I should
say Andrew you can still call him Lash you can call him Andrew or Lash either way but he's still
that guy that was married to May so like there's
this internal conflict going on inside of
that I think that they're going to flesh out
in future episodes I think they going to pick
that up next week let me just like look at
this picture here now obviously the person
that plays Lasch is a different actor that
they been put in the makeup is because he
grows so big but I just love this notice me sempai picture it's kinda like the Hulk
there's two different personas there's the
Hulk and then there's Bruce Banner two different
mind sharing the same body that is actually something
you get really hyped about in the next
Thor movie because even if it didn't come
across during Avengers Age of Ultron Mark
Ruffalo said that the Hulk is just as afraid
of BruceBanner as Bruce Banner is of the
Hulk I'm not expecting any kind of cerebral
Hulk anytime soon we might get a tease of
smart Hulk in Thor Ragnarok if you haven't
read the comics that just Banner as the Hulk
with his banner mind his mind doesn't devolve
into like the primal Hulk mind he gets to
be a genius that's almost indestructible and
that's not what lashe is but it's very similar like
what is Andrew's mind like when he is in Lash
mode my guess is that it's a different personality
in that like to two different personalities
inside of him that are gonna be battling it out
but on the number three mockingbird is back
in action finally off the bench May has to
like slap around a little bit obviously she
thought that Andrew was dead so that's what
she's on the warpath but this is like getting
mockingbird closer and closer to her spinoff
TV series Bobbi is one of the most interesting
characters that they have in their stable
Adrianne Palicki on top of that is one of the
best actresses they have on the show but they
have way too many cast members on the show
they need to kill like half of their cast-off
just they can spend more time developing a
few characters rather than spending a little
bit of time developing a ton of characters
so here's what I propose before the midseason
finale let Lash kill like half of the people
there on the show right now you just let me
know in the comments though like do you feel
like there are too many characters for them
to do justice on Agents of Shield right now and
the problem with Bobbi is is that Adrianne Palicki
can lead her own show she's like may and Daisy
put together so she's better than like both
of those characters so why do you need may
in Daisy if you have someone is better than
both when the show is built on Daisy she's
an in human so naturally you have to get rid
of Bobbi of Bobbi's Pentagon the spinoff on
the number two though Coulson and Rosalind
are now like the new most compelling relationship
on TV there like the best part of the show
that does not involve action and there is
little bit action like Coulson with his laser
finger the other week when they went to her
apartment which I do think is her apartment
like that the whole idea is that she's being
truthful with Coulson and Coulson is entrusting
her you got my favorite food you have a bunch
of my favorite stuff all over the place WTF
you try to win the over the ideas is that
Roslyn likes all those things like there are
two similar to the use the set design in the
narrative to tell you that she is a good character
she is trying to help despite the fact that
her casing up in humans looks like something
from her horror movies Coulson says and finally
on my number one WTF moment powers boost is
Gideon Malik the Hydra person that everyone
else is afraid of so i'll start by saying
if you have not watched deadwood watch deadwood
he is awesome on that TV show now the character
he's playing isn't somebody from the comics
it's an original creation of the show but
think of him as another head of Hydra cut
off one to take its place that there's always
going to be more heads of Hydra right now
Ward thinks of himself as another head of
Hydra. Baron Zemo the big one we're gonna see during Captain America Civil war and
I would say that some of his Hydra stuff will
tie in with Captain America Civil War I think
it will a little bit but if you member the
crossover with Avengers Age of Ultron
that was pretty disappointing last year
you could barely call that a crossover that
they did promise the TV show would crossover
with the movies more even with Thor Ragnarok
and I know a lot of people believe that this
planet here is the sentient planet ego
i totally buy that for now we we don't have
any evidence that says otherwise but ego the
planet is just from the Thor comics that that's
how you could type to Thor Ragnarok now the
idea of the sentient planet is pretty far out there
but if marble can do a talking tree that they
can totally do a sentient planet and Joss Whedon
brother Jed Whedon is one of the show runners
Joss Whedon isn't super involved
with Agents of Shield the way Joss Whedon describes
his brother is just in the most affectionately
weird way is like he just so weird Jed is so
weird so it's like the weirdest thing you
could do in a TV show it would be doing a
sentient planet I'd I really like that idea
let me know in the comments though do you
want to see Lash kill off like half of the
cast and do you think that this is the sentient
planet ego from the Thor comics what I'm hoping
is is that they resolve both of those questions
by the midseason finale's they can move on
to more Capt. America's Civil War type stuff
in the second half of the season everybody
just start pounding their desks we want secret
warriors we were promised and in humans team
seriously though I do think that we will see
an in humans team up before the end of the
season but maybe not before the midseason
finale what's cool stuff coming Agents of Shield
is getting a little bit more interesting with
the season and there there couple storylines
that I'm not a super big fan of
but i feel like is getting better with each episode it's a
lot better than last season and way way better
than season one so what's happening tonight
is I'm seeing Specter I'm also planning on
posting a Supergirl video my specter review
probably won't post till Friday but I'll do
like a non-spoilery portion in case you don't
see it right away but in the really big thing
is that BlizzCon is this weekend even if you
don't play warcraft anymore they dropping
the full trailer for the movie on Friday so i'm totally gonna do a video for that too lots of crazy
stuff happening i'll just be like sitting
at my computer 24/7 watching the BlizzCon
feed while you guys wait for all that to post you
can click here for the arrow Constantine video
from last night and you can click here to
watch the Jessica Jones trailer that is actually
coming at the end of the month that all totally
be doing videos for it so thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five and
I'll see you guys tonight!